part of our class one of our one of our
tasks is to figure out we've been given
a sum of money and we are been
instructed to kind of figure out how to
distribute this money to nonprofits and
organizations that we think are doing at
work and I wanted to ask you so part of
it is trying to choose right and I
wanted to ask you how you chose this
community of Guatemala to work with
specifically because part of what we're
deciding right now is Sri go sort of
more internationally should we focus on
something local should we do something
that we are really passionate about or
should we try and maybe maximize the
good that we can do somehow even if we
can even quantify you know are good to
begin with had to give a really tough
job in a way my job is easier because it
the community chose me and I mean we it
was just serendipitous it wasn't that I
went out and did research ok where am I
going to go you know I barely spoke
Spanish when I started so it wasn't bad
it wasn't a love of Latin America let
them but I do I tell the long story sure
ok in two minutes oh god I was on the
board of day methods his sister worked
for me for it you know he lived in
Charlottesville now he lives in Seattle
but his sister worked for me and when he
got to be famous he formed the
foundation and they asked me to be on
the board was through that that that I
found out about a young guy from San
Mateo a time who had a huge growth on
the side of his head and i'll tell you
the longer story later but the first
time i went to some idea was to take him
back to this town and that's when I fell
in love with it and it really did just I
mean I'd had these NASA nations in the
in my soul or in the back of my head or
something saying find something else but
when I got there we thought he was going
to die we did we had tried to find
treatment for him in Costa Rica how old
was he he was 34 yeah 34 and and they
couldn't fix
in Costa Rica later he came to New York
and lived with my husband and me for 10
months and we would go up to New York I
mean we live in Virginia so we'd go to
New York and had these treatments and
David Matthews paid for all of it how
much was that 369 thousand dollars Wow a
lot of money and he paid it when I came
back from Costa Rica we talked and he
said I'm sorry that didn't work out and
I said well I brought back the mr I'm
angiogram so I'm gonna try to find a
doctor here he said well if you find one
up I'll pay for it like I didn't even
have to ask he said he's incredible but
it was a lot of money but wouldn't you
think about how it got where it took and
did you find a doctor found a doctor in
at Beth Israel in New York is a Mexican
man named alejandro Berenstein whose
parents had fled Poland as young they
have fun you know Escape not see and not
see menace as children and met in Mexico
and he looked at me when I first met him
he said I think I think I can fix your
friend but I may be the only person in
the world that can but he did he thought
of his finger and he did any did
succession and the so Sebastian's home
now and it actually has been engaged in
the foundation that's he has been how
many years ago was that that was 12
years ago and it was while he was in my
house and he that I found out that there
never been a high school I had figured I
would do some kind of women's crafts but
you know cuz that's sort of what I do
but he I don't know what we were talking
about and he kind of casually mentioned
that they never had a high school and I
said really do you think they would like
one like that you know and so he called
down we had
phones in san mateo vuitton 88 there's a
town of 10,000 people and they're all
these community funds anyway he called
on two weeks later I got this official
petition so that's what happened it was
kind of then I thought well I have to do
it I didn't know anything about
education I didn't know anything about
nonprofit work I really didn't know
anything except that I want it but
except that this had been asked of me
maybe that's what it took to be asked